hey you edgy lulio is a little itchy
he's ridging his head current events are
big business human beings take pleasure
in listening to other human beings
discuss recent Topics in popular culture
even if they have no expertise on the
specific topic will in chat you must now
render your astonishing opinions on the
release of King Charles III's coronation
itinerary by Buckingham Palace this is
talk and topic time begin I don't
[__] care uh yeah I I am kind of
along with you I did read a few little
things about it here and there just saw
it going through my Google news feed I
guess he's going to be he'll become King
Charles
in May I believe they did release some
of the itinerary that it's going to be
concerts and they're going to be at
Buckingham Palace and then they're gonna
it's a three-day event and they're gonna
follow it up with um a day of service
where everybody in the kingdom is
encouraged to like volunteer their time
and [__] there ain't no [__] Kingdom
you know who's going to play that
concert for sure
they are Supreme
now
I don't know the lyrics
it is where we are all right Lion King
it's Elton John hey everybody we're
having a good time here on duty
d-o-d-z dude Z FM 10 000 on your fm dial
yeah I know some news about coronation
occasions what do you think about
generally speaking uh generally speaking
I think his ears are big hey he's got
big ears the ugly guy
what do you think about royalty
generally the British Monarchy
specifically I guess well I grew up with
the British Monarchy as an influence
growing up in a commonwealth country
yep we got the queen on our money that's
the thing I'm not looking forward to is
going home to Canada and seeing Prince
Charles yeah toony yeah Prince Charles
on it exactly and
um let's come up with some better people
to put on the [__] money let's get
some let's get John Candy on the money
let's get Brian Adams on the money let's
get Atlanta Jim Carrey
Michael Buble Alan Thicke uh Buble
Looney boob Looney
um
uh but uh yeah I'm gonna call I don't
get it either it's basically they're
just like at this point they have no
political power they're just a filthy
rich family you know and but they're
taking that money from the taxes of the
country right yeah yeah that seems
insane to me they also have just a
ridiculous wealth that I'm sure is set
up and accounts here and there where it
just swells grows and multiplies yeah
um here's one thing I'm going to tell
you at least have a good [__]
Instagram or something be a [__]
influencer like do something
Jesus
I'm never gonna not call that guy Prince
Charles I don't give a [__] what his
title is
who's Prince Charles oh right and he's
the one who was married to Princess
Diana uh yeah see this is when she was
assassinated right this is where we're
showing the difference between you and
me me growing up in a commonwealth
country I bet you didn't even have the
marks and Spencer department store at
your Mall no it was a very British story
you could go there and yeah Herbert
his little candied powder yeah it's
called sherbet you can get a Macintosh
uh the toffee Macintosh toffee nice all
sorts of flavor but yes they are they're
globalish
um the
the
royal family yeah [__] you bunch of
[__] you will never defeat the human
Spirit ah
I don't care if it's King Charles Prince
Charles
he's been in Bohemian Grove that's
that's yeah that's for sure well that
one guy prince Andrew he literally was
having sex with children on Epstein's
Island and how about that interview he
did on 60 Minutes or whatever where he's
like the whole I don't I don't even know
like what publicity uh uh nightmare
[__] people that were advising him
and certainly the queen was like shut up
don't say anything and he's like no no
no I've got this yes no well you see it
it was um impossible for me to have
perspired I don't sweat yes I have a I
have a rare condition where I actually
don't perspire and that was his bizarre
reasoning it wasn't no I I'm I'm not a
pedophile it was I don't sweat therefore
I could not of course have had the sex
with this young lady yes as she
described that I was sweating all over
it doesn't make any sense this logically
asked my brother the prince of Jesus
Christ it's insane I'll tell you that uh
When We Were Young yes we would uh
playing Polo uh on the fields and shires
as it were and uh no matter how rough
the ride on my Steed I still would not
sweat and could wear my my uh my
knickers uh old day without getting the
uh swamp ass yeah
what about that itinerary is that
anywhere online I'm not going to look at
it uh in the articles that I read it was
just kind of like they they Loosely say
what's going to happen over a three-day
period the coronation lasts three days
long there's a religious ceremony
there's the thing where all the other
Royals show up at Buckingham Palace
they're standing on the um you know like
a balcony overlooking all their loyal
subjects and everybody turns out for it
I I just don't I don't know I'm never
gonna [__] get it but I also don't
like any of the leaders or like
political figures that we have here even
if they are political figures to me it's
just like I don't want to [__]
they're super rich the kids are born
into this [__] crazy Rich family that
just has control and power for seemingly
no [__] reason and then we give a
[__] about what happens to them or who
they're dating or who they're marrying I
just start a new royal family yeah
bathed in blood
I mean look I will say that talk about
Bohemian Grove and all that type of [__]
I think the royal family is knee-deep in
that [__] I have no uh formal evidence
of this it's just conjecture but I think
yeah they're doing like real wacky
[__] [__] absolutely it's eyes wide
shut and uh there's there's nothing but
you want to talk about masquerade masks
these are people these are these are
inbred ghouls
breeding with with lizards and Aliens
people like Prince Prince what's his
face with his big flappy floppity ears
Charles Charles yeah uh folks uh we're
we're in a human War I believe in the
human spirit
and uh Prince Charles
who was is responsible for the death of
Lady die as as anybody as as responsible
as Rockefellers George Soros uh these
are people these people are uh
disgusting uh these These are these are
human-bound uh efforts of e p h o r s uh
Spirits yeah uh that are uh they're
they're um
extraterrestrial
and uh folks they need to be taken out
do you think he had her killed
no I don't know I think the queen did
that oh you think somebody did have her
killed though in the Royal Family
you know I don't know I think she was uh
yeah I think she was
she was such a sweet presence we did get
a [__] ton of the the Royals uh stuff
growing up in Canada they say about her
that her candle burned out far before
yeah
goodbye England's rose here we did a
sketch on Mad TV like a week after
Princess Diana oh Jesus dude well that
was a long ago time brother dude you
could make jokes about that stuff almost
immediately dude I played Elton John in
it and it was called you know funeral
songs and for 250 000 he'll Pat you know
he'll rewrite one of his classic hits
that's great you know goodbye Uncle herb
yeah you are the best Accounting in
Miami Beach
now you're in a better place where the
IRS can reach that's my Elton John
everybody and that's uh the sort of
thing you'll hear here on dudes the fmd
double o d z we got Elton John coming
into town he's going to be playing the
peony Coliseum uh two nights sold out
Elton John stay on the phone uh you'll
be winning the tickets I got Chad
coaching here from dude easy yep do Desi
hey tell us about it it's dudes it's
just like the radio station you work for
yeah dude Zoo that's right it's all
under the same Banner yeah and and
or [__] the royal family man it gives a
[__] [__] all the royal families what
gives a [__] since the internet there
should not be anything there shouldn't
be anything but the internet some of
them though have like legit power in
their countries like Saudi Arabian royal
family they actually run the whole
[__] show oh yeah if Muhammad bin
Salman not unlike um the the um
mysterious circumstances by which uh
Princess Di got into that horrible
accident yeah if Mohammed bin Salman
wants to take uh an America an American
journalist let's say like Jamal
khashoggi yeah somebody like that take
him to the uh was it the Saudi Consulate
in Turkey yeah I think so and dismember
them yeah and put them into seven duffel
bags yep that's the kind of stuff that
they're gonna do and that's what
Muhammad bin Salman and then you go to
Dubai where you've got women there in uh
Muslim Garb and headdresses not if
you're you know an American you could be
out there you could be on the uh unless
you're in the WWE oh yeah well the women
have to wear all the way to their wrists
they have to do completely but the guys
McMahon's about to sell it to him right
no I don't think that's going to happen
but I do think that if you're at an
exclusive party perhaps with prince
Andrew in Dubai then folks these people
are in Dubai drinking vodka mixed with
baby blood and and uh uh and Muhammad
bin Salman uh is a little bit lacks on
your headdresses and stuff is he drinks
alcohol snorts cocaine and masturbates
to white women in pornographic uh videos
on the internet okay but for sure but by
all means keep uh the royal family going
come in sit down
make yourself you think the royal family
will ever go away you think it'll ever
be dissolved if I listen to My My Pal
ciao what he says everything will go
away oh everything dies yeah planet
Earth will be turned to [__] dust
eventually just use that absolute then
yes but those the royal families could
be living in spaceships or some [__]
what they're ruling over or or how they
maintain their position I don't know at
that point but the Royal Family's
already lived in spaceships because
that's how they got there didn't realize
thank you moving on like whatever I
agree like whatever
review
like Duty here's what you do
please tell a friend then write a review
[Music]